[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de VIP
aujourd'hui j'ai la joie de recevoir
Elisabeth de Feydeau pour son nouveau
livre Elsa escaparelli l'extravagante
Elisabeth de Feydeau bonjour Véronique
merci de nous retrouver un nouveau socio
plateau vous êtes fidèle à TV 78 et je
vous en remercie j'adore c'est vrai bien
sûr
dites moi donc vous venez de sortir ce
nouveau livre Elsa ce qui apparaît dit
l'extravagante chez Flammarion vous êtes
aussi l'auteur de nombreux ouvrages le
Dictionnaire amoureux des parfums le
roman des guerlains car vous êtes
historienne du parfum en plus d'auteur
et plein d'autres choses
dites moi comment avez-vous l'idée de
parler de ce personnage c'est incroyable
alors Flammarion m'avait demandé juste
après la biographie des guerlains de le
proposer à nouveau un autre sujet de
biographie et je voulais cette fois
parler d'une femme une femme dont le
destin ce serait rouler entre la fin du
19e et à peu près les années 50 et parmi
ces femmes il y avait elsa-parelli qui
était pour moi un personnage
extraordinaire extravagant fantasistes
que j'avais rencontré d'une certaine
manière en fait sur le plan historique
au moment où je travaillais pour Chanel
parce que j'ai commencé ma carrière chez
Chanel et comme elles escaparelli a été
la seule et grande rivale de Chanel
forcément son personnage m'était apparu
et je m'étais intéressé à elle et est-ce
qu'on peut dire pardon je vous coupe en
quelques mots qui étaient Zaz qui à
Paris
née à Rome en 1890 le 10 septembre le 10
septembre 1890 exactement elle est d'une
famille aristocratique romaine son père
est un brillant intellectuel un
linguiste oriental qui dirige la
bibliothèque donc du palais Corsini et
par sa maman elle est issue de
l'aristocratie
voilà descendants des Médicis et donc
elle a ce cet héritage familial très
éclectique
aristocratique plus intellectuel que
fortunée mais où elle va être nourrie de
toutes ces influences pendant sa
jeunesse et donc elle a elle a une
personnalité en plus très à part dans sa
famille et alors qu'est-ce qu'elle va en
faire de cette personnalité quel est son
métier comment on peut définir alors
elle arrive finalement sa vie était un
destin incroyable parce que c'est vrai
que ce que j'explique dans le livre ça
aurait pu être un conte de fée elle
aurait pu avoir une vie d'une jeune
fille rangée est-ce que c'est ça un
conte de fée épouser son prince R comme
le souhaitait sa famille et donc avoir
et elle le dit elle-même dans ses
Mémoires avoir une vie confortable
finalement un peu oisive mais elle est
romanesque elle est singulière elle est
différente en fait des jeunes filles de
de son époque et surtout de son milieu
et elle a cette blessure narcissique de
l'enfance qu'elle appelle elle-même sa
lutte parce que dans le regard de sa
mère elle ne se sent pas belle à la
différence de sa sœur aînée qui est
solaire qui est magnifique et cette
belle Italienne telle qu'on imagine elle
au contraire Elsa elle a du caractère
elle a elle a de la personnalité mais
elle n'a pas cette beauté classique qui
est admiré par sa mère et donc elle
appellera sa lutte et Alfred salut si
vous voulez
un succès un destin et ça au fil de de
sa vie on va pas tout vous raconter mais
créatrice de mode elle est alors elle
démarre la définit alors si vous voulez
tout va démarrer à partir du moment où
elle choisit par amour d'épouser un beau
compte polonais qui en fait s'avère un
mauvais garçon mais elle aime les
mauvais garçons déjà donc mais qui est
très beau et elle se retrouve avec donc
son mari à New York au tout début des
années 20 avec pinceau en poche parce
qu'il a croqué toute la dot et au moment
où elle est enceinte elle se rend compte
que lui et volage et donc elle décide de
divorcer elle se retrouve si maire c'est
assez moderne quand même elle se
retrouve fille mère à New York alors
qu'elle est italienne
avec en plus une enfant qui se révèle à
18 mois être atteint de la poliomyélite
et là comme elle est
amie de tout cette on va dire cette
avant-garde artistique puisqu'elle a des
rencontré la femme de Francis picabi à
Gabriel pigalia sur le bateau qui l'a
conduisait à New York elle va
Gabriel picabial lui propose de repartir
en France et à ce moment-là donc elle se
dit après tout elle n'a plus rien à
perdre elle veut pas revenir à Rome
parce que ça c'est affranchi de ce
milieu familial par retourner elle peut
vivre sa vie exactement et donc elle
part à Paris cette ville qu'elle a
croisé au moment où
elle partait vers Londres pour devenir
fille au père quand elle était jeune
fille et elle se souvient Alain souvenir
enchanteur de Paris donc elle va
retourner à Paris avec donc Gabriel
piccabia et là elle retrouve un nouveau
tous milieu d'artistes surréalistes
surréaliste le boss sur le toit avant
Gad cette Café Society et comme elle a
un style incroyable oui elle est pas
belle elle se définit d'ailleurs
elle-même comme une jolie LED mais elle
a un style elle a une façon de
s'habiller comme les Italiens ne savent
le faire d'ailleurs et bien c'est c'est
copines riches de la confession Society
lui demande de l'aider de les aider à
choisir leur garde-robe c'est comment
cette histoire voilà et donc on appelle
ça styliste et c'est là où elle va
rencontrer Paul Poiret d'accord et
commence sa carrière de stylistes et
elle montre sa maison de couture alors
ça c'est oui après évidemment mais c'est
pour faire court exactement alors elle
elle devient styliste en même temps elle
est acheteuse d'art parce qu'elle a se
goiner qu'il vient de son enfance et
puis effectivement
elle va rencontrer une amie américaine
qui porte un sweat incroyable
extraordinaire qui lui tape dans l'oeil
et ce sweat est tricoté par des
arméniennes qui sont réfugiés à Paris
qui sont concierges en fait et qui et
qui tricote
une maille très particulière qui
accroche le regard de Elsa scaparelli
donc elles seront chez cette chez cette
arménienne arménienne qui se fait
appeler Mike parce que son nom arménien
est un prononçable et elle lui demande
de tricoter un pull dont elle a dessiné
le motif ce motif avec ce nœud papillon
trompe l'os blancs
parce que là aussi c'est l'air du temps
c'est entre les deux gars on est on est
oui on est en 1926 27
elle a une collaboration assez
incroyable avec les artistes notamment
avec Salvador Dali oui avec
manette Cocteau et c'est complètement
mot nouveau ça d'aller aussi loin dans
la création parce que pour parler
concrètement elle crée un chapeau en
forme de chaussures en coloration avec
Dali oui absolument alors si vous voulez
cette Café Society il se Boeuf sur le
toit etc c'est une petite société tout
le monde se connaît donc les artistes
que toi les créateurs de mode on le voit
avec Gabriel Chanel c'est la même chose
Gabriel Chanel est ami de Cocteau grande
amie Cocteau d'ailleurs mais pas pardon
la même façon de collaborer
Chanel est plus mécène alors que même si
par exemple elle va créer les costumes
du Train Bleu donc le spectacle balai de
Darius milobé mais au contraire ce
qu'apparelli elle va travailler elle
collabore avec eux c'est une c'est
vraiment une une collaboration d'esprit
en fait partie à artiste exactement et
avec Dali effectivement elle voit un
elle voit une photo de gala donc la
femme de Dali portant une chaussure à
l'envers et elle trouve ça extrêmement
drôle et elle va en faire un chapeau que
portera d'ailleurs entre autres gala
Dali comme la fameuse robe homard on
sait le homard la signification érotique
que le homard peut avoir dans l'œuvre de
Dali et elle va lui proposer sur cette
robe très virginale de de dessiner ce
homard entre les cuisses ce que portera
ou
ironique parce que on sait comment est
arrivé où elle est Simpson à devenir la
duchesse et donc quelle ose aussi le
porter on avait telle conscience enfin
voilà il y a une liberté sans limite
elle a la liberté sans limite elle est
singulière elle est et elle reste femme
d'affaires oui alors c'est pas son c'est
pas son sa meilleure
mais c'est pas son point fort quand même
des après des parfums oui alors après
oui et non parce que elle crée des
parfums dès les années 27 28 c'est
d'ailleurs son grand ami Jean-Michel
Franck qui découvre à la fois son
showroom ses appartements qui s'occupent
du premier packaging de ce parfum qui
s'appelle s elle a encore à la tout
compris est-ce comme ce qui aparelli
elle a analysé l'échec de son mentor
Paul Poiret dans le domaine des parfums
parce que Paul Poiret avait séparé
l'activité couture de l'activité parfum
en nommant la couture Paul Poiret et les
parfum donc elle a compris que c'était
une erreur Chanel au contraire elle
avait fait Chanel numéro 5 les parfums
Chanel là du coup elle se dit ça c'est
une très très bonne idée et elle ça
marque de fabrique ça sera le S donc
tout c'est parfums presque tous en tous
les cas démarrent par la lettre S sauf
le roi de soleil sauf le Roi Soleil il
n'a pas très bien marché d'ailleurs non
alors
je sais que ce qu'apparelli a vécu un
verset
oui elle a vécu combien de temps pendant
le drôle de guerre c'est ça
comment vous dites ce livre il est
passionnant ça se lit comme un roman il
se passe tout le temps quelque chose
c'est plein de rebondissements et elle
dit ce qui a pas Élie pareil la balance
du monde oui ça veut dire quoi alors
balance du monde il faut comprendre le
mot balance comme l'équilibre et c'est
vrai que elle est italienne elle avait
que à New York New York a eu énormément
d'importance pour elle parce que c'est
tout le modernisme c'est tout c'est la
liberté aussi aussi un des femmes et la
liberté tout court le monde des affaires
donc en plus elle s'est réfugiée après à
New York aussi dans les années 40 donc
pour elle Paris c'est l'équilibre entre
ces deux pôles si vous la vieille la
vieille Rome la fille la vieille hits
civilisation latine et la modernité de
New York Paris c'est c'est l'équilibre
et alors ce que je trouve aussi
incroyablement moderne c'est que elle
donne des conseils aux femmes des
conseils pour s'habiller et elle dit
acheter peu acheter du beau porter que
ceux qui vous que ce qui vous va quitte
à ne pas être à la mode oui parce que
c'est incroyable encore elle a connu
vraiment les vaches maigres en voulant
être une femme libre elle a connu les
vaches maigres même si elle vient d'un
milieu favoriser et elle elle a créé ce
qu'on appelait les séparables
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait pour avoir trois
robes elle en avait qu'une et enfin elle
avait une jupe et de haut voyez ce que
c'est déjà elle se crée des tenues avec
peu de choses dans sa garde-robe et donc
c'est comme ça qu'elle a effectivement
aidé dans les années 20 les jeunes
femmes plus fortunes et qu'elle a bien
s'habiller à se créer un style et
ensuite dans les années 50 quand elle a
fermé sa maison et qu'elle voulait un
peu se retirer de du monde des affaires
qu'il avait quand même beaucoup fatigué
aussi elle a eu des problèmes de santé
donc elle avait envie quand même de se
reposer un peu on continue à lui
demander des conseils et ces conseils
aux femmes sont d'une d'un pragmatisme
en fait c'est très juste il pourrait
s'appliquer aujourd'hui je veux dire les
12 conseils qu'elle nous donne ils sont
valables alors moi j'adore le 12e
conseil
alors qu'est-ce qu'il en reste
d'ailleurs de ces parfums alors il en
reste plus grand chose à part de très
très beaux flacons
si on les a encore il faut aller à la
smatak avec vous sentirez le chemin
parce qu'à Paris a été beaucoup publié
en revanche elle a été pillée c'est à
dire que elle inspirait l'exposition au
Musée des Arts Décoratifs vous retrouvez
mais absolument tous les créateurs
contemporains vous pariez tout à l'heure
de shopping de ce qu'apparelli dont le
flacon est en forme de buste on a le
classique de Jean-Paul Gaultier voilà le
shopping c'est le ressent Laurent on a
tellement de de comment dire
d'inspiration c'était tellement riche
exactement
on retrouve du Lacroix également dans
les broderies elle est incroyable elle
est elle est d'une créativité
éclectique fantaisiste
elle est joyeuse
elle a une vie qui est pas drôle si vous
voulez elle c'est énormément battue
quand elle parle de sa lutte c'était sa
vie a été une véritable lutte mais avec
toujours beaucoup ce côté italien quoi
très Dolce Vita en même temps très amusé
de la couleur
exactement écoutez moi je trouve que ce
livre il faut absolument le lire avant
d'aller voir l'exposition qui a lieu
jusqu'en hiver prochain oui
ce livre avant je trouve c'est pas mal
quand même oui bien comprendre la femme
dans son intimité oui parce que si vous
voulez l'exposition elle est très
anglais surréalisme c'est vrai que ce
qu'apparelli a été extrêmement proche
donc
et des dadaïstes mais quand on ne on ne
comprend pas toute son toute sa vie
toute sa jeunesse on a peut-être plus de
mal à rentrer dans le pourquoi en fait
de cette association avec les artistes
d'accord
prier que elle qu'avait voulu être
comédienne elle est quand même la
grand-mère de Marisa
berensongeant ce livre passionnant un
grand merci Elisabeth de fedo merci
beaucoup very et à très bientôt
peut-être pour un nouveau livre mais
j'espère au revoir à tous merci de nous
avoir suivi
[Musique]